this is why i think feminism is a female  supremacy movement i'm just keeping it  honest so there are just some horrible  facts of life if you choose to look at  them as awful it can also be a benefit  to be physically a woman that's my  perspective on it but the reality is is  that men are  faster they're stronger they can make  faster plays on the field where when you  watch female sports they're sluggish  they just move slower that's my that's  my perspective on it so they basically  wind enough to convince somebody to pay  them the same as men even though they're  not turning the same profit and then  what's the trickle-down effects of this  what what's the next area where women  are going to demand equal pay that takes  a sharp turn into communism and  redistribution of wealth i think it's  dangerous